Christmas 2013 an open church in the
interview Archbishop jihad ludwich
mullah Congregation for the Doctrine of
the Faith Archbishop Christians around
the world and preparing to celebrate
Christmas even those who are no longer
devout celebrate this feast what is the
secret what is the core of Christmas
nothing fire at Christmas we celebrate
the birth of Jesus Christ and God's
assumption of human form God comes to us
in His Son Jesus Christ takes on our
humanity accompanies us if God is there
for us humans we can also be there for
each other Jesus was born in a shabby
stable in Bethlehem the Bible says how
important is the theme of poverty in the
scene surrounding the birth of Jesus we
need sanity bought a zoo the armored
Gertz on so I mentioned in a closet is
part of our human existence not just in
relation to our wallets but also in that
we live in fragile bodies exposed to all
sorts of dangers that doesn't mean that
we are God's or we can place ourselves
above others but it gives rise to a
basic feeling of solidarity of all with
all that we also know that we are needy
her hands are open to God and he
presents us with everything everything
depends on his mercy India shanklin
zalazala st. runs on a cloud up in
Disney yeah this year the church has its
first pope from Latin America and what
is the feeling that suddenly everyone is
talking about poverty how does that
change the view of poverty and the
Christmas feast with such a pope exists
and is perhaps the Salinas Valley listen
it's a burden nichoza followed on dr.
scholl's now we have the great joy and
opportunity that has been given us under
that for the first time a pope is from a
different part of the globe than Yura
bites at least in the modern era de sal
business closer so it is I believe very
important that the problems of the
so-called third world but it is not the
third world
we all belong together that these
problems of many millions of people who
live in poverty and where the dignity of
humankind is questioned that these
people come completely into the focus of
the whole church but of course also for
us who come from the European context
many bishops are also talking about the
option for the poor in doing so they are
citing a key point of liberation
theology how political does a church
need to be to provide this option for
the poor I don't believe we are
political in that we are party political
or in any way trying to achieve
political power we want to focus fully
on the policy the overall cause of
humanity including the social dimension
and also emphasize these moral aspects
of our existence and introduce the
ethical aspects to the public political
discourse student and provision
discourse in Dodge there's much talk in
Germany about whether the church is too
wealthy whether we need a poor church
Francis encourages people to ask such
questions how rich or poor should the
church be globally and in Germany
vitamin Deutschland ice dome nation
Dame's industrial zone not wealth in the
sense that we use these worldly goods to
place ourselves at an advantage or to
represent ourselves presentazione on
substance or beaten zonin the church
needs the material means to fulfill its
mission to Berlin then untrue system
dies if there is a school system that is
maintained by a diocese or a national
church or by a religious order everyone
knows that that requires the necessary
financial means but no one would say
that that is a form of wealth compared
to other areas where these means are not
there doesn't must be end of his organ
I've done some internets if they're not
available then one has to ensure with
our international exchange that we from
a European viewpoint also help the
church in other parts of the world to
fulfill its mission in the educational
sphere and all
so in the social sphere or with
hospitals health provision and we need
the right balance between the ideal
goals and the material means that are
required to make them happen did
Susannah I alisya long pass cuz it's
sent visits your own biography is that
of a working-class child who grew up in
a suburb of mines in a working-class
family it's noticeable that the
controversial conservative theologian
jihad lavilla later Bishop an archbishop
long ago took to traveling to Latin
America to live among the poor to be
with the poor in Latin America what
attracted you what impresses you about
the people in Latin America ass penalty
and didn't mention battle America
DiSanto boy don't rest on zune a are our
brothers and sisters if you have a
background like mine you don't feel
bound by class distinctions but also not
led by a sense that one has to make it
to the top according to human standards
Lisa if one is a priest or just a
Christian it's about realizing the
ideals of Christ and being close to
people personally alishan aha tusayan
brother what has changed this year now
that the pbc has moved from Europe to
Latin America of course the Pope sits in
Rome but it's a different socio-cultural
background what does it mean Takuto and
background vez estas la Banque de menthe
Mazzone doesn't che mat toi sometimes we
think in patterns here is the center and
the periphery is somewhere else but the
center is also a spiritual word the
center is everywhere for the church
where Christ is present where he is
prayed to and exalted in the liturgy
where he is borne witness to in the
sermon and the Catechism as the
foundation for a successful life leben
or where he is present in charitable
welfare work we're in the poor the
suffering the hungry the thirsty we
ourselves see and encounter Christ
beginnin to that extent the Holy Father
is succeeding especially through his
origins through being formed by a
different view of the
world in overcoming this artificial
contrast between center and periphery
and in unifying the church around Jesus
Christ whose representative he is as the
visible head of the Church of God
Association bob duker toccatas how
important is the role of liberation
theology you are friends with Gustavo
Gutierrez one of the leaders of this
movement in ensuring that there can be a
figure like Francis Francisco scheme can
be socially estancia phone ana la
entrada zone the Social Doctrine is
provided to us by long tradition but in
gaudium at space an explanation of the
Second Vatican Council it was also
deepened Liberation Theology goes beyond
that by making quite clear that it wants
to be theology and not just a
contribution to social life on the basis
of natural law the recognition of human
dignity here the question is how can we
speak of the love of God in the face of
the suffering and the need of many
people who have had to endure their
human dignity being compromised and this
is not about the burn I'll issue of
someone's wallet being smaller than
someone else's essentially this is about
human dignity as catia condola gandhi
vention verde edible islam and every
person is created equal according to the
will of God and that's why a basic
standard is necessary that also
guarantees that human dignity is not
just an issue but he's realized emma is
an alpha vocalist third you're a German
Catholic theologian and once again a
German theologian is prefect of the
congregation of the faith Germany is the
country of the Reformation Protestants
globally are looking to their faiths
500th anniversary in 2017 a few weeks
ago Nicholas NIDA the chair of the
Council of the Protestant church in
Germany was here he was with the Pope
and also here with you what did two
leading theologians of these two
churches discuss when they meet how
close are you to Schneider's I'm
cognizant see Nicholas Schneider from
tuna tips inspire thousands if tens
intrusion 15 7
teen and 2017 are symbolic dates of
course but it also shows on the one hand
a will to renewal that comes from the
late medieval church root-and-branch
reform of the church that was a great
slogan but today we regard these
historical events from an ecumenical
perspective and more and more voices are
being raised including the chair of the
protestant church council including
important voices like bishop verba who's
responsible for the ecumenical movement
on the protestant side that we should
observe this date as a joint witness to
Christ before the world bear witness to
everything that unites us I enzyme
likeness valid as much there are
essential things that unite us and I
think that has to be the focus and we
need to avoid opening new wounds or
concentrating so much on historical
commemoration that old wounds are torn
open again saw a flick does sores on the
Alton bunton bid annoy of co person we
must close the wounds they must heal and
we need to continue on our joint path to
even deeper and more complete unity in
art in vodkas its threaten will we see
more ecumenical progress before 2017
such as mixed faith marriages or would
that be expecting too much yo self on
demands oh yes a joint document has been
agreed on the issue of communion c'mon
your tacos oven command shaft of azure
kazakh store there's an effort to deal
with the historic side of it this
controversial theology to put these
controversial points in a new light and
also the marriages that are joined in
christ and understood by us as a
sacrament between Christians even if
they are from different faiths nogizaka
mansion process Tyler of course they
should be able to partake of this
ecumenical progress and four zones for
evening ian and Familia and these mixed
faith marriages and families if they are
correctly understood
lived can certainly be a contribution to
advancing the ecumenical progress but of
course it cannot be that the status quo
of actual separation can be continued in
ultimo and that we say we will leave it
as it is where we get along with each
other quite well don't place each other
under suspicion that's under that stone
not seal massage the goal has to be
according to the will of Christ to
reconstitute the unity of the church and
renew it and that is also the
precondition as Christ says that the
world also believes in light of this
joint witness of all followers of Jesus
accident your excellency thank you for
the interview Merry Christmas fella
click the divine Merry Christmas